[Music]
fall Saturdays may be for college
football Sundays the NFL but you better
make way for pickleball a tennis
badminton ping pong hybrid pickleball
has been around since
1965. when families on Washington's
Bainbridge Island created the game on
this court to entertain their children
but over the past four years pickleball
suddenly become the fastest growing
sport in America with nearly 5 million
playing once thought of as an old folks
game there are hundreds of tournaments
annually not to mention Pro tours with
athletes like Tom Brady and LeBron James
each recently buying franchises in one
of the sports upstart leagues pickleball
has garnered an almost obsessive
devotion from players of all ages and
skill levels we decided to hit the
courts and find out why
one three
Southern California's Manhattan country
club offers members 18 pristine tennis
courts
but on a Monday afternoon in late August
we found most of the action on the
pickleball courts
it's a sport only recently entered your
Lexicon you're not alone
four years ago did you know what
pickleball was no idea never heard of it
now Club manager Ali Sullivan says
they're building courts wherever they
can we actually converted three of our
tennis courts over to pickleball so we
have six pickleball courts in place of
those tennis courts now is there still
even more demand than what you have room
for there is across the street is one of
our clubs in El Segundo and we actually
just converted our basketball court into
a temporary pickleball so it's it's
really any space that we can find from
the club
to the bar I'm looking around and it's
packed already it's 5 20. yeah Ryan
Weller helped open pkl in South Boston
just four months ago the community uh
response has been fantastic yeah we
don't have enough courts
pkl pairs a premium pickleball
experience with food and drinks an idea
Weller and his Partners got from their
own pandemic pickleball activity the
first time it was maybe three couples
and then the next day it was like six
couples and then it was eight couples
and then the next week it was like all
right you do the pre pickleball drinks
I'll do the drinks during the Mantra
here simple
One Nation Under pickleball is this like
the new bowling league
I personally think so we have an
eight-year-old birthday tomorrow
followed by you know 175 person
corporate event followed by you know a
mom and dad playing with their 20 20
year old daughter and her boyfriend you
know it's kind of a Melting Pot of
everyone Dan Cobra has already been here
five times and my fiance's parents are
coming next weekend and we're already
making a reservation for them get out on
the courts at Cheshire Park in
Connecticut
pickleball has practically taken over
Lynn Cherry's life for the past four
years you got it
would you be without pickleball right
now I honestly don't know
a former volleyball and Racquetball
player Cherry stopped playing sports
after she tore her ACL and once I saw
the game and I saw the size of the court
I'm like even with my bad knees I think
I can do this yeah not only did Sherry
start playing pickleball you now have
two books on pickleball she also
couldn't stop talking about it my eye
level is like about where the ball is
hosting her own podcast pickleball fire
and operating a website that publishes a
free magazine there's even a map that
allows you to search for the closest
Court in your area and a section on
instructions it's actually a pretty
simple game and it's very similar to
tennis since I'd never played she gave
me a quick in-person tutorial the ball
has to bounce twice so so once on each
side yes okay to start the game the
games are to 11. points are only one by
the person or in doubles the team that's
serving and what's the gray area in the
front of the corner work the gray area
is called the kitchen you cannot step
into that gray area and hit the ball in
the air
with the basics under my belt it was
time to give it a try thank you for the
very first time
players say the court size makes for an
intimate social experience you're
getting it now now the competitors
coming out that Fosters a friendlier
game it is fun isn't it it is even when
it's competitive
that's how Carol Levine described it
when we met her in California playing
with her daughter Jenny
whole new set of friends that I never
had like so many we spoke to Levine
picked up the sport during the pandemic
I think a lot of people were depressed
and didn't know they were depressed yeah
you know did you fall into that yeah
yeah when I got sick I definitely fell
into that after being diagnosed with a
deadly pre-cancerous illness Levine says
playing pickleball almost became a
matter of life and death
had over 16 surgeries in one year with
radiation and my husband's like I think
you really like it and I played and I'm
like wow this is easy I can do this and
it just like even my doctor said to me
I can tell you're like so much better I
mean I heard you say it it saved you it
did save me I'm in remission and they
didn't think that was going to happen
and I was lucky pickleball is life the
complete guide to feeding your obsession
Aaron McHugh turned her pickleball
Obsession into a book that touches on
everything from etiquette to how to
build a DIY court at home when you love
pickleball I think you become a little
bit of a missionary you want everybody
to play you want everybody to be as
happy as you are I'm going to use a
scary word is there a like a cult around
pickleball that it's more than just the
game itself I think so and you know it's
um I have a friend who said when I get
home from playing pickleball all I can
think of is when am I playing next and
with who and I feel the same way so is
there a cult well I don't think there's
an actual church but I play on Sunday
mornings and that's all I can say
McHugh is spreading the gospel of the
game she's helped build two courts and
developed a fitness program for students
at our sister's School in New Bedford
Massachusetts and for the masses there's
her book pickleball is life why that
title you know it is
so much fun and really what I'd like to
think about more is why isn't life more
like pickleball
you know pickleball is easy you can
always get better anyone can play you
can teach anybody it's inexpensive you
get healthy you meet new friends what
else is there why wouldn't you want to
do that why wouldn't you want to do that
so truly I can tell you I know I'm I'm
an athlete I've played Sports this was
the easiest thing I've ever picked up so
one of the things I took from people
people that had never played sports that
were able to play it you can play it
with all different ages and I think
that's what's connected with people is
that you didn't have to be great at
anything and right away you could really
get into it and because of that smaller
Court it was so much more manageable I
get it I get why people are obsessed
with it and then you take things like
pkl in Boston they've got chicken and
pickle I think in the South and in the
midwest you get it go to the bar hang
out with your friends and play as well
yeah but I could see the ball landing on
my food it's over in another Court
they're no they're no fences and you
don't need it that's the social aspect
which is what pickleball is all about
it's social it's either imagine you
trying to do more than one thing at a
time me where the food Michelle you love
it I'm sure I would it gets that heart
rate up by here